it's a big problem i'm out of run no it
was open
no no no
[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to seb containment
breach and we made it down to this room
which is of no use to anyone including
myself
especially myself but
or down
it is down i need to go down i was up i
thought i was down but i guess that's
okay because at least what that means is
that i don't have to deal with the
things in the underground
which i don't want to deal with okay
let's do this
no buildies no larry's no billy no larry
right i don't exactly remember where i
was or where i was trying to go
i don't know why that got me okay yeah
yeah you better run
yeah you bet whoa you're still there oh
that's a problem
hmm all right yay he's just chilling
he's just relaxing ah oh no no no
no not like this okay we're fine he's
chill he's stuck i think he might be
stuck i think he actually might be stuck
i don't think he actually might be stuck
okay cool let me just run blindly
through these hallways
this is fine i'll live
i will live and this will be fine good
stuff good stuff all right
cool look what are you doing here why
would you be here i shouldn't have left
all these doors open
really shouldn't have done that really
shouldn't it do that
really shouldn't have done the things
that i
do all right so i think the first floor
areas are clear and i've gotten
everything i needed there's no reason
that i should still be here
i've got the security card and i've
opened up the security areas for
whatever hell hole that i'm in
there's no more up to go it can only go
down sub level two
all right there's nothing in here that i
need i've cleared this one out too
so i need to go down to sub level three
because i have
a security office key it's not gonna
help me much toll
but i'm gonna go down anyway up level
three
right that guy's dead and i know that
guy's dead and that's
fine it's not fine for him but it's fine
for me
okay i don't know if any monsters
actually spawn in these areas like this
wrangler area
maybe not maybe it's kind of a safe zone
although i'm hesitant to assume that
anything is a safe zone in this world
i'm gonna assume that it's a safe zone
machine hallway and secure storage
okay that sounds interesting don't know
what machine hallway means
sounds deadly much like most things in
this game
sounds pretty deadly i'd probably die
from exposure to the machine
hallway expansion zone auxiliary
containment chamber
packing logistics storage
okay yeah that sounds good sounds good
to me
oh this don't look good this don't look
too friendly
don't look good at all actually zip tie
nice cable management
i love the blood red mist the blood red
mist is really
convincing of the quality of this area
the blood red mist i do so love the
blood
red mist i love the blood red mist
i love it ah good more blood red mist
i love the blood red mist the blood red
mist is the best mist
[Applause]
okay okay
whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
okay yeah yeah that's that's normal
what's in here
and why do i care the answer is there's
nothing in here and i don't care
great just gonna
go frick yeah frick my frack
i'm a ballsy [ __ ] i'm a ballsy [ __ ]
i'm a ballsy [ __ ] my big ol balls i'm
ballsies [ __ ]
whoo totally fine
all good baby all good baby
well good baby well this looks familiar
it's almost as if i went in a soy cool
but i don't think i did
blood red mist blood red mist
blood red little strange little strange
little strange
a little bit strange
please no what whoa what the hell i
needed to go down there maybe i don't
know
where are you where are you hey hey hey
hey i'm not closing doors behind me so
all right cool good great good
so the trick is to not close the what
i should have closed that door close
close close where am i what am i doing
what am i doing is he here
where is he oh [ __ ] where am i going
oh it's a big windy woo hallway why is
there another scp thriller
ow ow crunch smunch bunch
lunch don't do the scoops oh what if i
go in here
can i go in here i can't go in there ah
my scoops
okay well that was oh wow where did you
come from
what the hell man what the hell
jesus oh that was a big freak freaking
waste of my life
was the point of that i got another
scp-500 i don't know why that was in
there
what did i need that for nothing there's
no point that
hey do i need a double i don't think i
even need to go back i think i got
everything that i could have possibly
wanted
not that there could have been anything
else oh why
why i don't trust it
was it down there where was it
[Applause]
where are you oh that thing's not gonna
go away is it
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh dick yeah dick [ __ ]
dick okay yeah sure yeah it's gone yeah
wink wonk wink my
where is it i don't see it i'm blinking
wow this is good this is good this is
good this is good it's a good thing it's
a good thing
it's a good thing it's a good thing
all right cool
uh um
uh oh oh what the frick
what is that what is that supposed to be
what i thought about about me
ingest i wanna ingest
oh what is this one one seven six what
is
that what is one one seven six i don't
even know what this is
expand okay wait hang on let's play as
text and then inbigonate it
here we go 1176 is to be kept within a
sarcophagus it was recovered in
fully submerged in 1176-1 in a secure
climate controlled observation room at
site 48 1176 is not to be removed from
scp-1176 for any period longer then it's
necessary to conduct essential research
or replace monitoring equipment
no case exceeding six hours excess
scp-1176-1 is to be drained from the
sarcophagus using the attached faucet
once per day or as necessary to prevent
overflow and is to be destroyed or sent
for testing immediately scp-1176 is not
to be consumed by any incompatible
persons except for testing purposes uh
it's a mummified corpse of a human male
approximately 35 years of age at the
time of death clinically dead does not
indicate respiration circulation or
metabolism brain largely intact in spite
of general tissue degradation exhibits a
constant level of electrical activity
consistent with stage three non-rapid
eye movements sleep
in the blades of all bodies fluids are
found within a living human being
contains a fluid of viscous consistency
and golden color designated 1176-1
chemically identical to clover honey oh
determined to be edible by human beings
possessing a b
positive blood type and possesses
properties consistent with a highly
concentrated nutritional supplement a
dose
of 15 milliliters contains approximately
2500 kilocalories
significant quantities of essential
vitamins and nutrients making it highly
effective is an emergency ration or
staple food stuff
tests conducted on d-class personnel
indicate that consumption by compatible
persons is effective in preventing
physical sensations of hunger for 14 to
18 hours after consumption it bears no
long-term side effects persons of a
non-ab-positive blood type consuming
greater than 0.5 milliliters
begin exhibiting symptoms of severe
allergic reaction within four to ten
hours of consumption acute hemolysis
hemolysis lysis
followed by renal failure has occurred
in 98.7 of all tests where an
incompatible person
was fed this consuming among
incompatible test subjects are
consistent with symptoms of persons
giving blood transfusions of
incompatible type of their
so all right so it's a random chip let's
do this
anymore would be a bad idea
yeah right anymore would come on give me
that
am i a b positive am i lucky anymore
would be a bad idea dunk me in the [ __ ]
scooch over make room buddy i need in
you you want a snuggle buddy in there
you wanna you wanna snuggle partner well
that was great
glad i did that i feel good about that i
i should i save am i going to die in my
hemolysis
renal failure the edges of my vision
seem to be awfully
oh
i healed i got bad feeling about that if
i heal now
or if i save now am i going to die am i
gonna forever die
am i gonna be boned is this okay i
thought it was gonna kill me
anymore would be a bad idea i'm assuming
it's okay i'm gonna save
don't be a dick to me game there's no
other saved version
here i'm going for it i feel good i feel
good
i feel really good i feel uh
oh no oh wait problem
oh no oh no oh no no
no not like this please don't kill me
please don't tell me it's going to kill
me long term
oh please come on i i saved assuming the
dude will be good
am i going to die renal faily expansion
zone
what does this mean does it mean oh well
i mean i know what expansion zone means
i don't know what it means
in this category oh is this the
butterflies this might be the
butterflies
yes contain my ass
you can't contain my ass no that's not a
good thing
no that's not a good thing oh i'm dead
no i shouldn't have saved
oh disco duck
great so the cave notes i'm pretty sure
i've read those before i don't think
there's anything
amazing who cares cave note cave note my
ass
yeah i don't need to go here no stop
whispering to me
you goddamn pharaoh listen i didn't mean
to drink your honey
your skin honey that's gonna kill me
it's gonna kill me in the long run i
know it
my renals are gonna fail my renals are
that's not good that's what you call not
good it's one of those
ah this is a problem it's a big problem
i'm out of run
no it was open no no no i like that
whoa oh don't scoop me no
bro bro bro bro
bro bruh bruh the scoops bruh
your scoops
it's apparently a safe zone all right so
good hey i've got the power of the
pharaohs on my side
and that's definitely not gonna end up
badly for me it's gonna always be good
remember that uncle markimoo promised it
would always be
good i'll never break a promise all
right machine hallway secure storage
the only way to go now so if there's
nothing down here then i there's nothing
heavy
anywhere
yep totally fine because i got my ab
positive blood
i think my my actual blood type is a
positive so i'm pretty sure if i were to
drink this i would die
but but it's fine
okay i'm gonna go secure storage first
then i'll go to whatever the hell the
machine
right i remember the place not the best
not the best thing not the best place
okay ah a cola
i forgot what the cola does what does
the coladi do da
do what does the cold latte do dough do
hello oh hi oh no
no no no no no no i don't like it
i don't like it i don't like it oh i
don't like it
all right sure you you do your thing bud
[Music]
okay that was a little unnecessary that
was stupid um
okay yeah uh hi bye see you around
ah no no no no i need to go to the
machine
area
let me take these off my face ah god
yi gods
yeah music's kind of intense
oh hey buddy okay
all right cool good great great great
good great
that's a problem okay oh [ __ ] oh god oh
dick
oh dick oh dick okay okay problem
problem problem problem
problem
problem where am i where am i what is
this place oh dead end
oh god oh ye gods i'm safe now
i'm safe now forever forever safe
they can't get me here autoclave what is
this where am i what m do what
oh
[Music]
wow yippee
i've got no idea probably a reference to
something that i do not understand
all right glad i came all the way down
here for nothing
hey good job everybody on being an
[ __ ]
all right here we go
[ __ ] where was it really they're
really they really exceed on the
being an [ __ ] spectrometer i've
detected large amounts of [ __ ] in
this area
oh hey bud you look handsome all right
take
trois that's three not
two whatever who cares all right
here we go good good good
good the red mist will guide
my path i found a duck
but i also got the security admin
password
which is good because i can put this
into that
security office terminal that i found
before
there's no need pharaoh is that you
pharaoh i gotta trust in the heart of
the cards
summoning zodia perfect i love it
thank you thank you pharaoh thank you
i think it was on the first floor right
so i gotta go up two
did i get everything on the second floor
i don't know i did
perfect exactly what i was hoping for
here we go security office is what i
need all right
onwards
the whispering really isn't helping me
in this situation pharaoh
you know you you should just get your
message out and then it have that be
done
because the constant whispering is
what's really starting to make me
go insano in the in the brain oh so far
so nice
not really doing it to it to me not
really tuning it to doing it to me
ah i had to say a goddamn thing
all right here we go hi and goodbye
and one there pharaoh not now
goddamn pharaoh in my brain okay let's
close that
let's just close this door for a second
for a second go to here put in the
override do i want to do that
you were 5 hours 37 minutes late
what was that what happened
no no 1176 please
come back to me pharaoh come back to me
i need to drink more of your juice all
right so i've disabled the tesla gates
is that good though i don't know if
that's what you want
i don't know if that's what i want i
don't know if that's what you want i
don't know if that's what anybody wants
but i did it good i guess that's good
i guess that's good oh god damn it i can
make it i can make it i can make it if i
just go i can make it
oh god oh god oh god i'm fine
mitch mitch i'm fabulous you can't hurt
me
once i suck more pharaoh juice out of
his faucet i give him a sarcophagus suck
then you're gonna see oh you'll see all
right you'll see
what is it i don't have the pharaoh what
what's going on
i thought i heard some i thought i
thought i heard something
i thought i heard some a little
something you know what i mean a little
something some
huh all right so i disabled the tesla
gates so there must have been
something in like this original level
that is probably bad i'm not a hundred
percent
sure and i don't exactly know remember
where i came from i came from the
direction that had 173's containment
chamber because that's where we started
this whole
shindig so it would make sense that that
would be where i was
okay so six five zero who's six five
zero again
not remembering but i don't think i need
to go that way maybe there's another
level down
maybe it doesn't stop at three and let
me try that first before i go anywhere
else let me try to go beyond three
let me discover what it means to go even
further beyond
ah dick
douche all right so it's gotta be
something on sub level two
i don't know what specifically but
there's gotta be something
up here let me go in this one
i think i've been down this way before i
think i have but i haven't been to sub
level two in in a while actually i
haven't even explored any of it really
have i maybe i don't know
looks vaguely familiar
well nothing seems to be open but i find
oh the tesla gates down here okay
interesting and then this door would be
open yeah
yeah yeah yeah then i could open these
and i could turn on the light
yeah yeah yeah and then the medical hypo
medical hypo
more like medical hype okay okay
large bandage i'll take it i have to
draw it full
like a drop of regular bandage i've also
got a coca-cola
i don't know how beneficial that is to
me
whatever now plenty of heal plenty of
heal juice oh i can make it i can't make
it no
wait i can make it i can make it i can
make it it's fine i can make it
you're fine [ __ ] [ __ ] hey i can free
the dragons i forgot
i was here purge
there we go wow
oh hear me dragons
yes oh
i've seen this before but it's still
magical
oh wow
wow
wow oh
it's a flock of them beautiful
[Music]
that's nice
ah all right now time to leave and flood
the
argon forever there we go
that's nice that's real nice i thought i
was gonna get locked in there
forever forever and ever all right let
me just see what the the other one in
here it might be those eyeball things
i can't quite remember oh unless it's
914.
whoa god you suck you
suck oh [ __ ]
my goodness what was that no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no it is no it's not no it's it's the
eyeballs
does that mean i might be able to unlock
it with it yeah oh
fine 173 you win this round
i'll come back for you my little eyeball
buddies
you're gonna help me as you will you
don't even know you will but you will
so that's all the time that i have for
this episode here
thank you everybody so much for watching
look forward to more of this coming very
soon there they like
the detail that they put into this game
is very impressive the work that they
put in is really
really something so i gotta commend them
for that i don't know how much content
is in this update but it seems like
there's a lot
we've only really explored just a couple
scps here and they've improved him
considerably
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know i thought down in
the comments below
as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]
you